yeah even Native Americans
they're not gang members they most of
them aren't gang members they just had a
fight on the reservation he beat
somebody to death something like that
specifically with a tomahawk yeah
[Music]
do you guys remember a few weeks ago
there was a family
um Indian family lived in Pasadena oh
yeah driving in a Tesla off the side
could you hear about that and he drove
his family off yeah yeah yeah 250 foot
drop yeah the Indian yeah and then
everybody is fine
um I thought there's an interesting
development with it and I thought what
we would try to do now is kind of get
into the mind of the wife and try to
understand this
she
um even though initially
she told authorities like oh he's he
tried to kill us
um now she does not want him prosecuted
damn and she's trying to keep him from
going to jail did she say why or we just
have to speculate I mean yeah I guess
she didn't really say why but what what
do you think could be why I got two
angles okay angle number one yeah she is
a very what he's a very like forgiving
woman okay and she's like you know we
got to keep the family unit together no
matter what
the other one is more likely she's a
[__] [__] and she's like ain't
nobody torture my man the way I can
torture him so don't let him happen easy
and go to jail he stuck with me for life
that's what I'm doing she's a forgiving
woman and then she's the [__] [__]
[__] it's Friday is probably I'm gonna
torment him until his dying days I think
that's realistic though well that is
kind of true because remember we were
thinking he doesn't have any priors of
like anything but yet some kind of
stress went off on him to get to that
breaking point and wanted doing his
whole family but statistically we're in
this area
73rd here every single time we're in
this room it's like yo he tried to
murder the family what did she do to him
we gotta ask these questions why did she
deserve it
I have another angle that's pretty dark
okay I would say it's a bit of the
Stockholm syndrome okay she goes no stop
it you guys don't love him like you
don't know him the way I do I love him
wow so then she's like okay he tried to
kill us but so what everyone needs to to
get forgiven yeah Second Chances you
know it's like the the same thing you
hear when women are getting abused and
they're like oh I know he beats me but
he loves me yeah they become like
they're from Whittier yeah so it's like
I know he tried to kill me like four
times but come on it's because he's
passionate yeah you know he loves me so
much
do you think it could be anything to do
with uh when you know when you take like
the breadwinner from your family it's
harder to survive that's an option too
um isn't it harder to survive if the
breadboard is trying to kill you
it's also a possibility it is unless she
has some kind of angle with all three
put together yeah yeah maybe there's
some weird like legal thing or a prenup
that like gets expired and some weird I
don't know you know what I mean like
fifth option she wants to keep him out
of the jail so she can get him back
herself that's what I was saying
no no not with that I just mean like to
finish the job
in this situation she's not a [__]
apparently yeah she's not a [__] she's
gonna try to kill him I don't know we'll
see I don't understand dude Nick hasn't
finished writing the story yet yeah I
backed out what Joe said too does have a
lot of validity in the sense of like you
know um [__] get amnesia dogs yeah or
just be like I love him yeah it sounded
different the first time you said it I
like the bumper sticker version to be
forgetting yeah but that is true there
is like some kind of thing that is like
no like don't hurt him you don't like
when police respond to domestic violence
yeah then she got like a black eye
looking like a panda bear super beat up
and she's all like [__] frantic and
[__] so I just fell down the stairs just
bleeding [__] no like they're calling
the cops saying Hell my husband's
beating my ass riding in the cops come
they're like all right lady we're here
to help you and she goes nah never mind
but she's like don't take him though
don't hurt him just scare him yeah yeah
she ends up fighting the cops like you
never know stuff like that always
happens there'll be girls I'll be like
imma put a restraining order on they go
to court they [__] do all that stuff
and then they end up getting with them
still yeah like it go it's like love is
hard to resist disabilities people are
in deep deep love you can't stop it yeah
there might be I mean there's children
in play right yeah isn't he a dentist
yeah he's a dentist there's also a
difference in like yeah you know having
having to raise your children without a
father you know what I mean wait what's
the factor they don't want gingivitis
yeah
he read my mind
into right so that's probably a [__]
doctor of some sort
of dances he's a radiologist yeah she's
probably neurosurgeon
I see the neurologist or cosmetic
medicine and
that's guarantee bro I never met an
unsuccessful India my whole life I've
been trying to meet one can't yo you
know they did a whole income breakdown
of within Asian Americans how much they
make Indians are like top yeah yeah
that's good in America in America yeah
yeah India it doesn't seem to say that
Slumdog Millionaire I'm talking about
like well even he's successful but like
in in America
were there any Indians in jail yeah yeah
yeah yeah who do they roll with yeah
same thing they wrote others they're
Asian too technically oh so so is others
is in the same group with Asians yeah
Samoans Samoans Puerto Ricans really
they're not with the Mexicans at all
whoa I didn't know I mean they can't
they have a choice too but um yeah
Native Americans Native Americans roll
with the others too so the others is
Asian and all the others it's basically
not like if you're not white Mexican
everything that's not white Mexican or
black is other isn't it pretty cool to
be like we got a Samoan on our team like
that's yeah for sure I feel like he's
the secret weapon of the Asians because
you got like all these five foot Asian
dudes and you're like oh yeah well my
buddy over
[Applause]
dude those guys could beat the [__] out
of a lot what kind of crimes did the
Indians got Indian guys Tech crimes
obviously [__] rug pools
is gonna put him on level four yo
you guys are dumb dude is that what you
think
[__] crypto scams dude [__]
straight rug pulling great being a loser
in high school I did see my only ever uh
Indian gangster he was from Santa NASA
actually oh no way because Santa Nas was
so Multicultural so he was like the only
one and I thought it was very cool that
they're so inclusive it's not enough
yeah okay
interesting animal to choose like the
American animal right okay so the Indian
guy yeah what what was you could have
said elephant but it was an Indian guy
was there was it a gang or just like
individual Indians no it's individuals
they'll do something like maybe shot
that shot somebody and killed somebody
you know like there was a truck driver
who I I think he was yeah he was Indian
he shot somebody
um at a like road rage dispute oh so
he's not really like a thug this is more
like a crime of passion yeah even Native
Americans
they're not gang members they they most
of them aren't gang members they just
had a fight on the reservation he beat
some guy to death something like that
specifically with a tomahawk yeah
y'all trying to make like the street
fighter of gangs and [__] like yeah
[Laughter]
he's cute yeah like Cuban Puerto Rico
yeah in the movie he was a brown guy
yeah he was yeah
oh what a brown guy what who Blanca oh
in the movie in the movie The
Jean-Claude Van Damme yeah bro I didn't
know that that movie was Canon I thought
they just they just threw out the window
he's technically Brazilian oh yeah he is
he's supposed to be Brazil he's supposed
to be like an Amazon Marvel type deal
isn't he supposed to be green though he
is yeah but he was he was in Greenville
they got trees down there in Brazil you
know oh Brazil he's not supposed to
represent the people the way like Miss
America from Brazil looks like also Zane
gave us from USSR not Russia or whatever
so different times
[Laughter]
where do the Russians go do they go with
the whites yeah yeah
are the Whites
um all like race-based gangs or no
um no not not necessarily bro there's
like white Crips in there there's white
Bloods yeah but they they they sometimes
there's white essays too like from essay
gangs you know but they all have to
usually roll like wood Peckerwood or
whatever like that's the Nazis not not
neces there's different yeah there's
different ones yeah but Peckerwood huh
that's what they call them the woods are
there like unique instances though where
it's like you talking about there's like
you know white Crips or white Bloods and
then like if they go into the prison and
then there's like all the black people
but are Crips and bloods they can't roll
with them no sometimes they there are
people who do that but if there's a riot
they're gonna get those people like they
don't respect that you know what I'm
saying like you mean the white people
get that white people that's that's on
the black side yes because it's not the
the they're like the white guy's on the
side of the black guy like race fry and
they're like like that no no oh okay
is this like prime target number yeah
they're like that's in rush hour they
all look alike it is they stick out they
stick out like a sore thumb it's because
they probably grew up uh grew up in a
black neighborhood exactly but they
don't respect Eminem dude they don't
like that guy
that's why it's like people the kids who
join gangs nowadays like they have to
understand because they don't rap they
don't like calculate prison right like
right prison is a whole nother ball game
you can't be doing stuff like that I I
remember like there are certain people
who came and they were like Korean but
they were from a Mexican gang and
they're like we got it we want to go to
the you know the Mexican side and the
the OG Korean dude is like try it and
see what happens and that's all he said
and then they were like I guess we're
gonna go over here bro you know like and
yeah so it's yeah he's like he said I
have to live here you guys are making it
hard for me to live here I don't want it
where it's all like like that you know
when he said try it did it was it almost
like a threat like if a riot goes down
I'm taking you out first or face no it
was more like I'm gonna take off on you
now like whoa before you even get
indoctrinated or accepted into them
basically whoa damn yeah so it was
really crazy you know and now and this
was the most harmless looking guy
but he was a lifer though he was a
murderer he just looked like a regular
dude no tattoos no nothing real short
dude but he was gangster for sure
so the guy from Pasadena is he's gonna
make it out
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign